presumably you'd be coming off the bench
playing with the second unit that's a
lot younger than this the Warriors of
the past have been with JK and Moses
just what do you think of of their depth
their their bench players that you might
be playing alongside uh you coaching
oh okay well I don't know what is what
the situation is going to be yet you
know what I mean so I think that'll be
for us to to figure out once we get
going
you have no career is that something
that you'd be willing to do
um like I said it'll be a conversation
for us when Camp starts or whatnot but
me and Steve have talked or whatnot but
uh you know that ain't something you'd
be like what up man where are you
starting coming out you know what I mean
so I think we'll figure all that stuff
out in Camp